hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast i'm your host john
carroll
and if you're like me nothing makes you
happier than talking to people you
disagree with most of us i think go out
of our way to surround ourselves
with people with utterly different
perspectives it's so
boring so tiresome to talk to people who
think you're right
what we would like is to always be
talking to people who have completely
wrong ideas from our point of view
well anyway that's what we tell
ourselves sometimes
uh most of us would actually say if you
asked you know yes of course i love
having a diverse selection of opinions
exposing themselves to me all the time
but in fact in practice
okay sarcasm aside many of us find it
more
comfortable find it more easy to be
surrounded by people we kind of agree
with
or at least when we disagree it's in
relatively mild
ways and the academy
colleges and universities is no
different from that
and the academy for various reasons has
leaned toward the liberal side of the
spectrum
for a very long time and i think it's
true i think that the data
uh back up the idea that it's becoming
more liberal
over time so we can ask why this is we
can ask whether it's a good thing or a
bad thing and that's what we're going to
do today in our discussion i'm going to
talk to musa algarvi
who is a sociologist a member of
heterodox academy for a long time and
someone who's really
i think done a very good job of sort of
putting people's feet to the fire
in the public sphere in being honest
about
their commitment to intellectual
diversity this is probably a good place
for me to
tell a story that musa actually told
while we were recording but due to
technical glitches
the recording didn't come through so i'm
going to try to tell it not quite as
well as he did but you know it
it helps illuminate his perspective
where he's coming from
when he was a graduate student at the
university of arizona
he was a teacher there an instructor
there
he wrote an article for a left-wing
publication that was critical of the u.s
military okay it pointed out that
the military's activities in the middle
east have worked to destabilize things
uh that the military had conducted
torture and mystery to prisoners and so
forth
various claims that you may or may not
agree with or you may not like the
framing of them but they're certainly
within
the realm of acceptable opinions that he
should be able to have about these
things
but because his name sounds kind of
arabic and because he's muslim
and he made critical remarks about the
us military this was picked up by fox
news
and so fox news started a little
campaign they criticized him this caught
on and other
right-wing outlets let's say that and he
got a lot of
death threats and things like that the
university of arizona sort of disowned
him and said you know
it wasn't us uh please don't take away
our funding that kind of thing
and interestingly what moosa's response
to this was was to say you know what i
should do is write for more right-wing
outlets you know if he's just talking to
people who are already ready to hear the
message
that he has then he's not doing as much
good as if he reaches a different kind
of audience
and so he has done that writing for
national review and elsewhere and of
course being active in header docs
academy
and his claim is that this has helped
him be a better scholar and thinker
because you have to
really think about what you're saying
when you think that the audience you're
saying it to might start out being
skeptical
so i don't think we're going to come up
with any answers here i don't agree with
musa on everything he doesn't agree with
me on everything
there you go right but the point is i'm
not giving this podcast
as uh a solution to the solution to
these problems
i think it's a conversation we should be
having after all as i mentioned in the
podcast
uh when it comes to hiring new people
for your department
it kind of makes sense you're more
likely to hire people you think have
correct ideas than incorrect ideas right
we all know that astronomy departments
don't want to hire astrologers we all
know that
physics departments don't want to hire
flat earthers or anything like that
and you can say well those are facts
they're not values but
i think you can make the case we don't
want political science departments to
hire
objectively pro-fascist or pro-nazi
point of views we don't want child
development
departments to hire pedophiles or
pro-pedophile
advocates there are some ideas we don't
want to engage with
so why is it the case that a large
majority of academics turn out to be
liberals or leftists is it because
people who are conservatives select
themselves out or is it because
conservatives are discriminated against
and you'll be not at all surprised i
think to learn that it's both
like many of these things actually are
so i'm on the left side of things myself
as you may have gathered over the course
of many podcasts but i
actually do want to think that it's
better
to be surrounded by a diverse set of
ideas but ideas that sort of
uh it if even if i don't agree with them
i think they have something to offer and
i think this is actually
you know hopefully reflected in the
selection of podcast guests that i have
i am very interested in talking to
people i do disagree with
but only those who i think have
something to offer and it's an
interesting and very difficult
distinction
to try to make so i'm not being you know
i don't have a feeling of superiority
here with any of my academic colleagues
i
recognize how hard it is to truly walk
the walk when it comes to intellectual
diversity
but i think it's an important thing to
try to do and to try to understand what
its limits
as well as what its benefits really are
so that's we're going to try to do
let's go
welcome to the mindscape podcast hey uh
it's good to be here thank you for
having me
i think it's gonna be a fun conversation
i have planned it out
even less than i usually plan out my uh
podcast conversations because there's a
lot of
issues that are kind of tied into each
other in different ways
where it's hard to extract you know a
narrative from the beginning to the end
but i hope we can talk about a bunch of
them
um and they're also fraught issues right
these are issues that are intellectually
important but also
politically and emotionally fraught so
that's what i really liked about
a lot of the things that i read on your
website a lot of your essays is that
you're
you know you're clearly trying to be
fair and analytical and rigorous
about these fraught issues so maybe the
best way
to dive in is through the first essay
that i read which introduced me to your
work which was
about the heterodox academy where you've
worked for a while and
have stepped down from so maybe you
could uh set the stage a little bit by
telling us about heterodox academy
and um especially in the in the article
i read it was about some of the
more recent challenges that it's been
facing sure so
uh the objective of petrodox academy is
to
promote um constructive disagreement and
open inquiry
and viewpoint diversity on institutions
of higher learning and by viewpoint
diversity we take a more holistic
approach which includes
um diversity along the sort of i guess
the more standard
demographic dimensions that most people
in academia already care about
more or less um you know for instance
race gender socioeconomic status um
geography which isn't which is i guess a
lot of people it's not controversial but
it's sort of under
um emphasized um and then um
but then also including sort of
ideological diversity and we focus a lot
on the
on the which by that we mean mostly
religious and political diversity
although that's not the
full extent of ideological diverse um
yeah so
uh so the organization was uh founded to
promote uh
those things and um basically
you know it's been an epic journey uh
through the organization
over the time that i was involved uh
with it so we were uh
we were formed in early 2015 and at that
time
most people including the founders of um
of heterodox academy
were assuming that hillary clinton was
going to win the presidency
and um and so we were engaging in this
conversation
from a standpoint of assuming that those
of us on the left were going to be
were coming from a position of i guess
strength and could
um and could afford to a
and and should be more generous right
generous in victory or whatever you know
however you want to frame that
uh but then uh the election didn't go
the way that a lot of people were
expecting
and so the message um and so talk trying
to engage with
uh others on the left about uh about why
this was important and about why they
should
care about it in the age of trump at a
time when
they're very concerned about you know
when they're seeing
horrible things happening all the time
and their people are
panicked and uncertain and you know i'm
freaking out about the future
and where he's the president is saying
repugnant
things and they're assuming that his
supporters must also
be of a similar mind or else why would
they have voted for him et cetera et
cetera so
trying to make the case for why um for
why these things are important
in the climate we found ourselves in
shortly after we were formed
was a very different sort of landscape
to navigate than the one we had
initially been
the one we had initially been expecting
to enter and then after the election you
know
uh it got worse there was um there are
these major campaigns to try to
you know basically troll students who
are um
especially students who are uh you know
shaken up
by the election and the way it went and
there and so higher ed became
um issues about hi and so oftentimes
these people who are trying to troll
these students got the reactions they
were looking for there were these big
altercations
blow ups and campuses nationwide so by
the trolls you mean you know people
inviting
especially provocative speakers to
campus hoping to get
a rise and a cancellation so they could
act cancelled and like the victims is
that what you mean
absolutely so i mean sometimes uh
sometimes people are invited to campus
and they're
and they have something uh because they
because they have something
substantive to contribute to the
conversation and the people want to hear
them for that reason
and um and even if they're controversial
you know it's uh that was should be
respected right they should have
the right to hear from the people that
they're trying to engage with or learn
from
even if they're people that we disagree
with but in some cases in many of these
cases
people you know were inviting people
like uh milo yiannopoulos who doesn't
have anything particular to say
um he's like his whole schtick was
literally just
trying to provoke people and he and he
would write essays about this
like uh he had one in breitbart that was
something like
how you can how you can beat me but
spoiler you won't basically
where he was saying something like um
i'm gonna come to your
to your area i'm gonna try to trigger
you i'm gonna get the reaction i'm
looking for because even though you know
what i'm trying to do
you won't be able to resist giving me
the reaction i'm looking for
and that will you know etc so there are
these people
there became this um this whole kind of
dynamic where
a lot of groups would be inviting
speakers to campus
basically just to troll other people to
to get a reaction
yeah and then when they got the reaction
they were looking for it made them
seem like their opponents were
reactionaries
um right who you know and and again they
they were kind of being reaction like
they didn't have to give
the people the they didn't have to give
the reaction that these people were
trying to solicit
but it's also at the same time as we
recognize that it's also important to
recognize that
the people they were engaging with
weren't necessarily engaging in good
self
yeah everyone is uh dragged down a
little bit by this
yeah and so the and so this was the
environment and sort of
uh in which heterodox academy was trying
to find its footing
um so there are these major blow-ups the
at
campuses nationwide there was this made
there was a significant uptick in fire
in um professors being fired for uh
political speech
on the left and the right on the right
uh mostly led by uh fox news oriented
you know
fox news campaigns uh which i have some
personal experience with
and then on the left you know a lot of
times it was sort of student-led
um campaigns to get someone fired for
saying something they didn't like
or otherwise reference things uh and it
you know escalated even to the point of
physical clashes in some cases
um culminating i would say probably with
the death of heather heyer
and that uh at universe virginia um
and uh and so you know we recognize that
the uh i guess the our initial approach
to the problem which was like
here let's make some arguments and
present some data
about why this is important like that
wasn't going to cut it
for the kind of problem the kind of
situation that we were
um facing post 2016 uh
so we were try so we tried to be a lot
more systematic
in how we uh thought about the problems
and tried to address them
we started developing different tools
and resources
we developed a robust a much more robust
organizational structure to help move
projects along um a much a different
membership structure
to to fold more people into the project
and uh
and sort of um and pull pull their ideas
and information and resources and stuff
and disseminate them
um and so now uh heterodox academy
uh is we have i guess they have about 4
500 members who are
primarily faculty but also grad students
and administrators
from all around the country um i stepped
down in january of 2020
and so i haven't been like super
involved with uh
a lot of the sort of day-to-day
operational stuff there um but
but yeah at the time i left um you know
we're a very different organization
from the one we started with we had a
totally different approach to
talking about and engaging on these
problems and uh
yeah it was just a pretty wild journey
it's interesting because it's
sort of the flip side of um or not maybe
not the flip side but
a different version of what will
wilkinson told me about i had him on the
podcast and
uh he works for a libertarian think tank
the miss cannon center
and they had plans uh for what happened
when hillary clinton would get elected
namely they would work closely with
people in congress to sort of
nudge everyone in a more libertarian
direction and you know
reach across the aisle and so forth and
all those plans went very much out the
window when the actual election results
came in but there's there's sort of how
we respond to the moment and then
there's the bigger picture so
you know i'm sure that there's plenty of
listeners who are uh have heard
of the issue of intellectual diversity
in the academy but maybe
don't know some of the numbers so the
background
fact that you're responding to and we
can talk about what the right response
is but there is a fact
namely that professors in the academy
are
on average much more liberal than people
in the country and then
uh is that good or what can we do about
it right i mean what
tell us about the founding impulse for
having something like heterodox academy
yeah well i'll say at the outset
actually one ironic thing
i guess one ironic thing about our whole
um about our whole
positioning in the lead-up to the
election is that we were assuming like
everyone
will work i guess the the leadership of
heterodox academy was assuming as were
most people that hillary clinton is
going to win
but part of the reason people had that
over confidence that hillary clinton was
going to win
ironically was because there was a
certain kind of group think that had set
in
along the expert class it's the very
kind of problem there you go
the heterodox academy was supposed to be
you know
um responding to uh i was one of the
people
who had predicted the election would go
the other way like consistently
starting in march 2016. um but um but
my view was not the predominant view
right um in the organization
or you know in general and uh
and so um yes but so basically
the academy skews about uh you know most
people in the general population
aren't hardcore progressive or
conservatives and that's true in the
academy too there's a lot of people
who are um moderates but the but people
who are highly educated
um and uh especially people who are
highly educated
tend to be more partisan than the
general population so there are
once you once you so when you haven't so
p among those who are
um in academia you're much more you're
less likely to be
kind of in that middle centrist kind of
position you're someone who's
more likely to be decisive you know more
decisively on the left or right
and among those who work in higher ed
it's the ratio is something like ten to
one
uh left to right in social research
fields and about
five to one left to right in the academy
overall
and um in terms of political diversity
and that matters um that matters for a
number of reasons
uh i'll say so some examples of how it
matters
it matters in terms of how how questions
are sort of framed and understood so for
instance is inequality
a problem uh in what senses are is it a
problem or is it a phenomenon that
should be sort of understood
on its own term uh the predominant
approach is to
start by assuming inequality is a
problem that must be rectified
and it's a problem um that that is
described as
originating in very particular ways uh
for instance it's pretty much
exclusively the actions of people in the
dominant class
whatever dimension of inequality you're
looking at uh socioeconomic racial
gender
um sexual orientation whatever dimension
you're looking at it's people in the
dominant class so whites men
rich people heterosexuals whatever who
are um
who are responsible for inequality and
or
it's replication and there's sort of an
asymmetrical way in which these problems
are
uh and there's there's a value to that
but but at the same time
um there's a lot that's sort of over
it's a highly in virtual being
a highly constrained sort of conceptual
field there are
a number of phenomenon and dimensions of
these problems which go
underexplored or not explored at all and
that can often
undermine our ability to actually
understand and address the problems that
we're trying to um
solve so so that's uh yeah and and it
and it's not just
and in addition to the sort of i guess
epistemological
um problems related to the lack of
viewpoint
diversity in higher ed um there are also
sort of
more pragmatic problems about the reach
of our research and the impact of our
research
and the viability of our research so for
instance you know most people in the
country
are religious but social researchers
tend to be pretty not religious and kind
of uncomfortable talking about religion
or
talking about things in religious ways
um
and so this undermines in a world where
people were more comfortable
talking and engaging with these
different kind of metaphysical and moral
frameworks we would be more effective
at activism we would be more effective
at making the case to policy makers in
some cases we would be more effective at
convincing ordinary people about
why what we do matters and should be
supported and to the extent
that people don't that people in the
general population don't feel
like their views or their values or
people like them
in general are represented in
institutions of higher learning
they don't necessarily feel like they
have a stake in those
institutions and in fact often support
them being you know
uh cut um monitored surveilled
interfered with
because they assume that it's other
people who are sort of
uh that it's some class of people who
are not like them
using these institutions to attack or
ignore or override the will of people
like them etc
um so so in addition to the
epistemological consequences i guess
the short is um we also a lot of
academics have a difficult time
engaging with the public and policy
makers and
about our work as a result of these same
shortcomings for any business
one of the most high-stakes decisions
you make is who to hire
and when you're making high-stakes
decisions it's important to have the
best
possible information you can as soon as
possible
that's why indeed.com is the place to go
to get access to the largest pool of
talents you can hire the right people
fast
indeed.com is the number one job site in
the world because
indeed gets you the best people unlike
other sites indeed gives you full
control
and payment flexibility over your hiring
you only pay for what you need
you can pause your account at any time
and there are no long-term
contracts plus indeed provides powerful
tools to make your search much easier
with 73 percent of online job seekers
visiting indeed each month
indeed is going to get you the important
hire you need like they have for over 3
million businesses
right now indeed is offering our
listeners a free 75 dollar credit to
boost your job post
which means more quality candidates will
see it fast
try indeed out with a free 75 dollar
credit at indeed.com
mindscape this is their best offer
available anywhere so go right now
to indeed.com mindscape terms and
conditions apply offer valid through
december 31.
my react my action is that you know
there's a so many things to unpack
here and it's it's it's fascinating and
difficult to get it all right i mean
i think the most important thing i want
to talk about is
why if and why and when and under what
circumstances intellectual diversity
is important but let me not ask that
right away because i
you've already gave given sort of some
basic answers and we'll dig into it
deeper but
there's some things i know are going to
instantly
be brought up in people's minds like
okay if there's a five to one ratio
of liberals to conservatives in academia
why is that
and number two let's just stick with
number one there for a second i mean
what are the best explanations is it
because liberals are smarter
and better professors or is it because
conservatives are discriminated against
by narrow-minded liberals or is it
because conservatives self-select out
and they join industries or think tanks
or
and how do we even know what the answer
is yeah um
so so it's a comp it's a it's a
complicated phenomenon and
uh the short answer is that it seems to
be
a combination of i would say it's
primarily
a combination of discrimination and
self-selection and
those two things are related to each
other so
for instance um and and the reason and
the reason we know that it's not
that conservatives are just intrinsic
are just intrinsically
bad scholars or not interested in the
academy or you know these kinds of
narrative
is a few things one that until the mid
90s or so
the um the ratio of liberals to
conservatives in the academy was much
different
um so sam abrams as a political
scientist at sarah lawrence college has
some good data on this
you really saw this shift happen in the
professoria around the mid
90s um and so uh and and
it's a shift that corresponds to
changes in the political makeup of the
geographical
areas of the country where universities
tend to be located as well
uh interestingly enough so i think um
so i think part of the shift is
responding to sort of
broader socio-cultural trends and higher
ed
one thing that happened around this time
actually a little bit
prior but kind of around this time is
that there be
is that there emerged um is that think
tanks became more of a
thing um and so you saw the emergence of
of
you know heritage uh brookings that
existed before that but you know
uh heritage cato um other institutions
like this
so for libertarians or conservatives who
felt
ill at ease in the academy because um
because even though the the ratios were
much closer than they are today
you know the academy has been a
consistently kind of left-skewed
um institution for as long as um
i mean there's research on this going
back you know to like uh
um going back you know decades um it's
it's it's
had a cons a pretty consistent left skew
um
but it hasn't been but it wasn't like it
is today so what you saw
you know i would say around the mid 90s
as you saw the emergence of these sort
of
um alternative academic centers where
people could do
research and they could um and pursue
the kinds of questions they wanted to
to pursue and using the methods they
wanted to pursue
um without worrying about uh without
worrying about their ideas being spiked
um for instance in peer review or
institutional review boards and things
like this
um we do know that there is uh
that there is a number of biases in
things like
peer review institutional review boards
um hiring
and promotion committees we know this
from empirical research it's not just on
along the political dimension it's
actually along a lot of dimensions so
along race for instance along um gender
lines along the lines of sexuality in
many cases uh
but the political and religious
dimension is one dimension in which this
kind of discrimination occurs
um and to the extent that and then there
becomes this kind of self-reinforcing
dynamic
where a lot of people go into the
academy
thinking that an academic career is
out of their reach because the academy
is skewed
and the skew is increasing and there are
these potential
uh concerns about uh discrimination and
things like that so they
don't even try necessarily to to even
become a professor they instead plan
from the outset to move on to a think
tank afterwards etc right and so you see
this kind of
um self-selection effect that that is
responding to perceived discrimination
um and so it's kind of a a a weird
gnarly feedback loop that we're in right
now and so this is the point um one of
the things that i talked about
in um in a couple of my essays is that
like
so the goal of an organization like
heterobox academy isn't
to have the academy have institutions of
higher learning
perfectly mirror the ideological base
rates in the general population
right or the goal is to
create conditions under which regardless
of what one
ideological sensibilities are um your
work is
going to be that you're not going to be
subject to this kind of discrimination
and that there's
not this kind of capture um over over
certain
institutions um and especially certain
sort of uh
sub subfields of knowledge one
interesting thing that you see
i'll just note also about the
conservatives that are in the academy
today is that um for the ones that
didn't exit the academy
most of them um increasingly they try to
work on
topics that uh that are
non-controversial
uh dive into political things and
they're and they kind of try to stay
on the dl yep about what their political
leanings are about anyone's time
yeah and there's a few reasons for this
again uh part part of it is that they're
worried about
um about you know uh having their work
spiked
and things like peer review or whatever
but then part of it too is like you know
they don't want to
end up being that person who they walk
into the room and everyone rolls their
eyes or they
have something to say right like there's
kind of a social dimension through this
that also
matters no one wants to be a pariah in
their department or anything like that
so mostly they um a lot of the
conservatives who remain in the academy
today
um try to work on sort of non-political
issues
and or try to keep their political
leanings kind of close to the vest
and so one consequence of that
ironically though is that um
we don't even we're not even able to
reap the epistemic
benefits i guess of the ideological
diversity that is in the academy
because what of it there is it's kind of
concealed
in many cases um uh and and so we've
been talking about the political
dimension but this is also true
uh like i said along other lines along
religious lines
uh for instance well i i wanna i'm gonna
actually use this as a
as a sort of jumping-off point for um
digging a little bit more deeply into
this
justification for when and why
intellectual diversity
is important because uh there's
certainly a tension
going on here right um on the one hand i
think that a lot of people
if you just asked is diversity important
you know
along uh intellectual as well as other
dimensions they would probably
give a sort of boilerplate positive
response to that right like
uh some million idea of the free market
of ideas let a whole bunch of things be
bounced around but there's the on the
other hand
we have people who are lifelong
committed to their intellectual
endeavors and they think that certain
points of view are correct
and certain points of view are incorrect
right and uh i mean
i'm in a natural scientist so i see that
in very non-political contexts where you
know
certain departments have nothing but
string theorists in them and other
departments will never hire a string
theorist and
so how do you balance the idea that you
know i'm sure that
i'm sure i'm very i shouldn't say sure
i'm very
open to the idea that people with
liberal political leanings
will end up discriminating de facto
against people with conservative
political leadings how do you separate
that out from uh just a substantive
belief that these people are on the
wrong track
i mean i think it uh i think it i think
the discrimination is fundamentally
rooted in
as you said in this in this exactly it's
funny um
there's this tension in certain surveys
um there's there's a sociologist at
colombia his name is sheamus khan
and along with colin jeromek who wrote
this great essay
on what's called the attitudinal fallacy
which is basically
basically what they argue is that in
order to understand what people
actually believe it's not enough to kind
of like ask them
questions but to look at behaviors right
so in the abstract when you ask people
do you support
free speech do you support diversity do
you support
anything like like as you said people
overwhelmingly say yes
but then when they're faced with
difficult cases
in their local context and in fact you
don't even have to look at
actual behaviors in the world because
sometimes you can actually
elicit a similar effect when you just
present them with concrete cases
um even even in polling so for instance
one essay that i did
um was focused on the results of a uh
of a cato institute um survey on free
expression on campus and so
when they asked students like do you
support viewpoint diversity do you think
people with controversial views should
be able to speak on campus et cetera
people overwhelmingly said yes
yes yes great great great but then when
and you but then you present them with
like specific examples
like this um do you think that um
you know uh this wasn't from the study
but like off the top of my head
uh like um do you think that uh
someone who you know is a is a hardcore
um
sort of uh trans-exclusionary feminist
should be allowed to speak on campus
right
a lot of people who said oh yes the
viewpoint diversity
go i don't know about that though or or
um should we invite someone who um
should we engage with someone who says
who who wants to do a talk
about um about inequality but focused on
the role
of african americans in um
in the perpetuation of ritual inequality
they'll be like well i don't know about
that though
or you know you can go on down the list
right so um if you ask them in general
do you support this
do you support engaging with views that
you disagree with
everyone says yes of course i do i'm
open-minded everyone thinks they're
open-minded everyone you know etc but
then when you present them with cases
that actually challenge
their core beliefs then they're like uh
and this is a phenomenon that you can
see in polling um if when you
zoom into specifics but it's even more
clear when people are forced to confront
these kinds of decisions in their local
context in the real world when there's
actually things that stick right
so for instance with faculty hiring
decisions this whoever you bring on
um when you're when you're hiring a new
faculty member is someone that you can
expect to work with for years
you'll have to make decisions with about
who to bring in to graduate
you know about which graduate students
to admit or not about um a whole range
of other things about how the department
is structured
um and so these are high-stakes
decisions that have a lot of sort of
uh so if you feel like so if you feel
like
this person is is sort of fundamentally
opposed to things that you find
important or valuable or whatever
um it's going to be difficult to uh
to justify it it'll be difficult for a
lot of people to feel like
even if they believe in diversity in
principle when the rubber meets the road
if they could pick someone who's sort of
an ally to themselves or they can pick
this person
who they disagree with assuming their
records are
kind of comparably you know everyone
sort of clears the bar of whatever
meritocratic
decision procedure they have then people
tend to gravitate towards the person
who's more like them the person who's
going to be an ally the person who's
going to advance the cause they care
about
rather than the person who's not um and
that's a normal impulse that people have
but the problem is when everyone makes
that same kind of calculation
and virtually all institutions of higher
learning
have a sort of decisive left skew and
social science departments haven't even
more pronounced levsku right
then you see this kind of then certain
kinds of perspectives are sort of
systematically locked out
of the academy in general because no one
because everyone else is making that
same calculation that you're making
um and so this is one of this one of the
challenges so
one of the and so the tension is and
this is where
this kind of work gets hard where the
rubber meeting the road gets
challenging where it's legitimately
challenging is convincing people
that in certain circumstances you
actually should you should try to bring
on
this person that you disagree with
instead of the person who's the ally
um because it will benefit it will
benefit the academic community
it will benefit the knowledge
environment and but it brings it brings
its own challenges you know diversity
brings challenges
with all that's going on in the world
right now it can be hard to focus on
things that are
long-term and kind of annoying but
nevertheless important
and surely buying life insurance has to
be up there on the list of such things
policygenius.com is here to help it's a
marketplace it's not an insurance
company by itself you go to policy
genius
and you can find different insurers
offering you different plans and figure
out which one is right for you
right now you could save 50 or more by
using policy genius to compare life
insurance from different
insurers and the process is simple you
go to the website
in minutes you can work out how much
coverage you need as well as comparing
quotes from top insurers to find the
best price
and policy genius will let you know
whether for example you can skip the
in-person medical exam
and then once you've chosen your policy
policy genius themselves will handle all
the paperwork
all the red tape the best part is they
work for you not for the insurance
company so if you hit any speed bumps
along the way
they will take care of everything so if
you need life insurance head to
policygenius.com right now to get
started you could save 50
or more by comparing quotes policy
genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice to get it right part of my job
here is to be the devil's advocate so i
i can't help but ask this
question you know if i if couldn't i
take a
an attitude that this is exactly the
kind of issue
that should be solved by the free market
if we find that there is systematic
discrimination
against a brilliant conservative isn't
that a wonderful
opportunity for certain departments
to corner the market by hiring all these
brilliant conservatives that can't get
hired anywhere else
i don't necessarily buy that argument
but i'm curious as to what your response
is well
so there there has been a market
solution um and almost
uh an almost literal market solution and
that is the emergence of these private
think tanks
um that have that are taking all of
these conservative
um intellectuals and whatever who feel
like they don't have a place
in the academy overall uh the problem
though uh what you see as a result of
that
is that basically neither is you get
these two sort of separate ecosystems so
you actually lose
the benefit of diversity happens when
you have these different viewpoints
actually engaging with each other and
having the answer to each other and
clashing with each other and
exposing one another by but instead what
you see is two
separate echo chambers you have a sort
of think tank echo chamber
with a lot of um right wingers or
religious people or whatever
kind of um talking amongst themselves
without much of a challenge referring to
one another's work etc and then on
within the mainstream academy you see a
similar phenomenon
on the left and so there's technically
diversity in the sense of
there are conservative intellectuals a
lot of them outside of the academy
but the benefits of diversity that you
get from putting these perspectives into
um conversation with each other by being
challenged
uh etc by collaborating by having
people with differing views actually
collaborate on on projects and
etcetera none of that's happening and in
fact what have
one consequence of that is that a lot of
the
institutional structures that we have
like peer review or institutional review
boards
committee decisions they're sort of
they're fundamentally premised on the
idea of this kind of adversarial
thing that you would have people with
diverse frameworks and views and
whatever
um hashing it out and so as a result
these kinds of committee decisions
like um peer review and institutional
review boards and committee decisions
whatever
will push us towards a more objective
more
truthful more accurate you know
understanding of reality towards better
decisions more objective sufficient
cetera but in a world where the people
making decisions all
share the same the same axioms the same
blind spots the same um uh assumptions
about the world
then you can have then rather than
correcting biases
by means of things like peer review or
committed decisions you can actually
exacerbate
ex biases like um as a result of these
uh processes that were supposed to
correct the biases
um and i think that's the um that's
that's been the consequence of taking
the sort of
uh of taking the sort of um i guess
hands off
uh i guess the nonchalant perspective
that
you know look if they don't fit in here
they'll figure it out you know someone
will
you know uh life finds a way that's a
jurassic park metaphor
but i guess the point is uh they did
find a place where they can do
you know where they can do research and
pursue scholarship and whatever
but it's just there are a whole bunch of
negative consequences for this and one
negative consequence ironically for
institutions of higher learnings and
academics i'll say is that
a number of policy makers then the think
tanks from the very beginning
in um think tanks like heritage uh and
aei
etc were tightly connected with policy
makers with
practical applications and as a result
of the fact that institutions of higher
learning don't really have
an especially specific field don't
really have a lot of political
diversity and are perceived as being
partisan
fields um there's a whole range of
if you're a republican policy maker and
you're trying to
um formulate say a response to
um a response to say covet 19 or
something like that
you're not going to one um you're
probably not going to consult
say a sociologist about you're not going
to look at like what does sociologists
have to say about this if you're a
republican lawmaker because your
assumption about sociology
is that all the sociologists that's
going to tell you is you're wrong you're
stupid you're evil
you should probably become a democrat
right if that's what you think you're
going to hear from a sociologist if you
ask for their opinion about something
is basically you should abandon entirely
your whole
sort of premise and approach to policy
making um
then you're just not even going to waste
your time you're going to ask someone
maybe an economist instead and then and
this is part of the reason why
economics has this kind of prestige it
has among
social sciences compared to other fields
like anthropology and sociology
is because it's relatively less skewed
it's still significantly skewed
in favor of the left but less so and
even left-leaning economic
economists can sort of are known to like
talk and engage with
people on the right in an amicable way
and can often sort of
you know in a way that's different from
say the reputation of sociology or
anthropology or
you know but this brings up this brings
up a different way of
being a devil's advocate in the in the
following up on your
the start starting point of how things
have changed since
you know the trump election and so forth
like are there people
who would say if asked you know
i have no trouble talking to i'm a
liberal i'm a progressive i'm a leftist
i have no trouble whatsoever with people
in my department saying that the free
market is a best engine of growth i
might disagree with them but
i can talk to them i have no trouble at
all talking to people who say that god
exists and you know they go to church
every day
but i don't want people in my department
who say that you know
gay marriage should be illegal or we
shouldn't invest in africa because
black people are too stupid to use the
resources that we give them
i just think that's too dehumanizing to
allow in my department uh is that a
different
kind of issue are there are there
intellectual
diversities that uh it's okay to not
want to have
so i mean yeah so so any yes so there
there are always
um there are sort of limits so i
the way i always talk about it and think
about it is that viewpoint diversity
i think should be understood best as an
instrumental good rather than an
absolute good
so it's valuable for the purpose of
increasing our knowledge and
understanding about the world
um helping us engage with the wider
swallow
of of society etc you know you can
list the ways in which it's
instrumentally valuable but it's not
something that you pursue just for its
own sake
in my view um and so to the extent
that and so they're implicit in that is
is an idea that there could be
things that fall outside the scope right
so if it's
um they might be hard to decide what
they are but they might be there
yeah yeah so i mean it's tough question
it's not a question that that you can
easily answer
it's a question that has to be worked
out by intellectual communities sort of
responsive to their
to their needs and priorities and things
like that
um but but so for instance you know if
you're a geographer
you don't necessarily need a flat earth
geography person
or something like that right so these
kinds of like paradigm cases that people
evoke
um to say um but you know shouldn't
there be some kind of limits yes there
should be some kind of limits
but the problem is right now um i would
say is that
is is uh we're very far you know
so i guess the point is this there there
is a sense in which
in principle viewpoint diverse these
kind of a campaign for viewpoint
diversity could be overly permissive
folding in a bunch of viewpoints that
actually aren't valuable for helping us
understand the world helping us
understand society things like that but
we're very far from that
and um one of the tensions is uh
again is is that um and i guess one one
helpful distinction too
is to draw a line between um is that
it's helpful to think
i guess between sort of empiric like uh
just purely empirical problems which can
be resolved
like uh or more straightforwardly
empirical problems again
uh so questions about whether or not the
earth is flat versus the actual problem
versus yeah versus sort of social
questions
about that involve um sort of that take
you beyond
just questions about facts but also into
questions about values and priorities
the sociologist gil ayal
has a good um has a pithy way of putting
it as trans scientific
questions yeah i mean this this this
really makes me wonder what to do and
i'm this is i'm not playing devil's
advocate now this is something where i
truly don't know what the answer should
be
on the one hand it makes perfect sense
to say unlike
facts values are not shared by different
people and therefore we should have
diversity of values
because we can't just do an experiment
to decide who's right on the other hand
i
can easily see people saying but these
values that that person has are just out
of bounds i don't i don't
you know those deny my basic humanity
and i don't want to engage with them so
uh i'm sure this is a hard question to
answer but how do we decide which
which values we want to be diverse in
with respect to
yeah it's kind of a hard question to
answer but i mean i think some helpful
uh guidelines or or ways to sort of
structure the
so so one of them for instance is um if
it's a widely held view
that a lot of people in society hold
that a lot of policy makers hold
then it's a kind of view that you're
going to have to engage with and that if
you don't engage with
it's actually probably going to be
counterproductive to to
to advancing you know whatever your
values are
if you just can't even talk to or
understand where other people are
from so so when you're talking about
sort of weird niche views
um that uh not too many people hold
then those are the kinds of things which
can be more
safely excluded although still under
certain circumstances there might be con
you know reasons to um engage with them
anyway
they uh but for things that are sort of
that there's
millions and millions of people in
america who
who you will have to engage with or
policy makers or whatever who hold a
certain view
and if you're saying that's out of
bounds that's something that i'm not
even going to be able to deal with or
talk about or whatever
then that's a problem that's a problem
for you in a very practical sense and
that's a problem
also again in in and so so for instance
on on the question of uh whether or not
to return to to one of your examples
about say
you know gay marriage or something um
that's a that's a topic in which
americans have moved substantially
over the last you know 10 years right
but but there are still a number of
americans who
who hold the view that you know um
marriage is a
religious sacrament between a man and a
woman etc and if you
and if you're putting it beyond the pill
to even um talk with those people
or understand where they're coming from
or engage their perspectives and views
um then not only are you then you know
you're doing then you're undermining
your ability to one reach those people
and then two um in some cases you might
be even undermining
your ability to understand well that's
the sort of policy
but you might be under undermining your
ability to understand the phenomenon in
question right
um so so i guess that's one thing is
like if it's a view that's sort of
widely held that a lot of people in
america hold then it's a view that you
should be able
that you should probably be engaging
with um and this is so for instance
uh and you see you see that's playing
out in a few ways so for instance
with the election of donald trump a lot
of social researchers like
they can't imagine how anyone could
reasonably vote
for donald trump that is a problem
because it is their job to imagine
that right well and so a consequence of
that is that a lot of the research
on trump and his supporters basically
starts from the premise
that there must be something wrong with
those people so they try to explain
trump votes in an uh by looking
specifically at pathologies or deficits
so
um there are whole studies that are
literally designed like
what best explains why someone would
vote for trump is it that they're more
racist or sexist or authoritarian or
ignorant right and so all the options
are bad
it can't be that they voted for trump
because they you know
are patriotic or whatever um that they
love their families or they're concerned
about you know
um so all the options are bad and
there's not a symmetrical analysis
with respect to why people voted for say
hillary clinton right
um like they don't sometimes they
measure the extent to which they try to
frame trump votes as motivated by
sexualism for instance
but don't explore the the extent to
which these same factors could explain
hillary clinton votes
or um and and there's just a lack like
if
if someone designed a study that was
like why would someone vote for hillary
clinton
is it because they're communists or they
hate america or right or something like
that
we would immediately go well that's a
prejudicial study design
that you know um uh not you know
but when it when it applies to the uh to
the trump voter
you know there's that's a perfectly
normal thing
um and and in the impulse that sort of
generates that this is a a kind of thing
you see in a lot of fields right
and not just with respect to trump
that's just an easy example because it's
you know current but researchers in
general approach situations
by thinking thinking that they're that
their own
views are correct that's why we hold the
views because we think they're correct
so our own sort of theoretical
perspective metaphysical views moral
view
etc um and so uh one consequence of that
assumption though
is that we tend to assume that uh we
tend to use our own
our own sort of position as the baseline
against which others should be measured
and then deviance from that baseline is
often explained again in terms of
negative attributes some kind of
deficit some kind of pathology um and uh
and this even holds in cases where the
scholars themselves
hold demonstrably idiosyncratic views so
on a number of issues
on on a range of things academics are
kind of
weird with respect to the rest of
society
like the way we talk about things the
way we think about things but then
but when this when when academics notice
a divergence
between how they think about the world
and how others seem to think about the
world
the question isn't usually why do people
like us hold such videos and try to fuse
on this matter
right the question is what's wrong with
everyone else such that they can't see
the obviously correct answer here um and
so
uh and so and that matters that well
that matters for a few reasons
like one of them for instance one
consequence of this sort of
other oriented blaming other people kind
of
approach to social to studying social
issues
is that there's sort of is that there's
often sort of blind spots
so i've i've written uh a little bit on
for instance um racial inequality racial
inequality in the united states i have
an article at a recent republican
sociological forum uh on this um
where people in the professional what
what is
often called the professional managerial
class um often when they're trying to
understand something a phenomenon like
racialized inequality
the first people they look at to assume
as the bad guys as the
as the people who are responsible for
racialized inequality
are the millionaires and billionaires
the one percent et cetera it's like
these these
elites over here are the ones who are
responsible
for this problem the issue with that is
that millionaires and billionaires can't
just sort of
don't just sort of make things happen as
if by
by magic they work through institutions
right institutions run
by the professional managerial class so
um
uh if you want to understand how a lot
of these phenomena happen
you have to look at media organizations
and institutions of higher learning and
government bureaucracies
these are the institutions through which
the one percent exercise their will
it would actually be impossible for a
lot of these conditions to be maintained
without the active participation of
people in the professional managerial
class but to the extent that they focus
that people within that flat don't look
at their own actions and behaviors don't
consider the way their own
institutions serve to reify and
perpetuate these states of affairs
they have a poor understanding of how
the social phenomena come about
of what to do about them um and uh yeah
so
i mean there are there are significant
consequences that that sort of flow from
this blind spot so this so i think we
can finally get to the uh
question i i suppressed way at the
beginning which was
what are we gonna do about it or you
know what is a strategy for dealing with
it i really liked uh one of the essays
you wrote on
uh diversity training programs
and how you know their their hearts are
in the right place
diversity is good and they're typically
diversity training programs for you know
uh racism and sexism and things like
that not for political or religious
orientation uh but you point out that
they generally are not
effective in actually fixing the problem
it seems like
this problem of uh viewpoint diversity
within the academy would be
even harder to solve in a systematic way
or is it
is the strategy just to sort of bring
people's attention to it
to sort of let them self-correct because
their hearts are also in the right place
hopefully yeah so the the
um yeah so the i mean the diversity
training thing
i'll just bracket that actually okay so
so yeah the the general strategy though
the general hope is
um when people say things like i said
you know
i believe in engaging with people i
disagree with i believe in
like i don't think that they're lying
about that i think they're sincere about
that even though when presented with
concrete cases
a lot of times they have this kind of
like
reaction right when it's time to put
those values into practice that turns
out to happen
less than maybe they're aware of or
would desire
so living those values is tough so what
heterodox academy
and other initiatives like it are trying
to do is provide people with tools and
resources
um to to better live those values so a
lot of people so for instance if you're
a professor
and you're like you know what i think
maybe we should be engaging more with
say conservative or religious
perspectives and studying these issues
but
you're not conservative and religious
you don't know too many people who are
you don't even know where to start so
like how would you design a syllabus for
instance
on racial inequality that folds in
conservative or religious perspectives
if you're not familiar with them
yourself
right it would be hard um and so
but what we can so what harder docs
academy is trying to do is provide
people with resources like template
um so this is one thing that we're
trying to do now is crowdsource for
instance
syllabi made by people um who
who who support the mission who have
tried to who have tried to
sort of incorporate conservative or
religious perspectives
into their exploration of some of these
issues if they've taught a class at
least on the syllabus and it went really
well and it was valuable
then like our perspective was like share
it with us this is a resource that other
people can use right so we can
crowdsource
what works um to lower the bar to lower
the amount of effort
it takes for people to put it into
practice so that's one
sort of plank is trying to crowdsource
what works from other people
and learn from that um so that we're not
having to reinvent the wheel
each of us you know from scratch because
that's that's a high bar i mean that
that in itself
often disincentivizes people who agree
on principle but don't know where to
start so they just kind of uh do what
they've always done
um and then uh but another plank
i guess is is drawing people's awareness
to the problem
so you know people know that the academy
skews left for instance or that
you know it's a secular institution but
they're less aware
maybe of one how dire the sku is
um and uh two um the fact that it
that it's not just kind of an organic
thing that happens but it's a thing that
people actively
you know create through discriminatory
behaviors or actions that they might not
um even be necessarily aware of so
making them aware of them
um can help um and can and and spelling
out the consequences
of you know if we don't have these kinds
of diversity here's how it
messes up our understanding of the world
here's how it undermines the viability
of our research in the future or the
impact of our research here and now
etc so spelling out the consequences um
is helpful
for creating a sense of urgency around
the problem
um and uh and then cultivating
sort of communities of practice i guess
this is related to the crowdsourcing
thing
but putting people in touch with one
another so if you're someone who's
concerned about this problem
but you don't but when you look around
your department you don't necessarily
know
that anyone else is concerned about this
problem or
you know um then it can be hard to to be
the one to kind of
um right but if you know that there are
a whole bunch of other people in your
field who are also concerned about this
who are committed to doing something
about it
then we're trying to sort of create
communities where
people within different fields um can
collaborate together
think on this together work it out
together because what we don't think
what heterodox academy doesn't think is
that
they're in a position to just kind of
decree like this is what must happen
but but we are um we you know these are
again these are questions that
intellectual communities have to work
out we within themselves that different
fields have to work out that different
you know universities have to work out
in accordance with their own needs their
own priority etc
so we want to facilitate them doing that
that's the main role of heterodox
academy is to help facilitate those
efforts
i think but at the same time one thing
that we have to
um one thing that we have to that we're
concerned about and that we're trying to
and that motivates some of the urgency
we have around this problem is that we
recognize
that there are people in this country
all around policymakers
ordinary citizens etc who also recognize
um who who are not patient uh who are
not content to let
academics figure this out themselves
either because they won't trust the
academics or because they think the
problem has been going on too long and
there's nothing
changing or maybe it's even getting
worse or whatever and so there are all
these external stakeholders who are
trying to find ways to
intervene in the academy in a way that
runs contrary to academic freedom
that runs contra that is often kind of
these ham-fisted interventions that make
things worse rather than better
politified things more rather than
pooping down um
and everything from fox news campaigns
to get people
fired to you know uh state legislators
legislatures defunding you know
sociology and
other fields like that like as has
happened in wisconsin
uh to interventions um at the federal
level for influence like trump and his
attempted um uh executive orders on free
speech and things like this
so if this isn't a problem that so i
guess the urgency for us is that we
recognize that
um this right now these are problems
that we can try to address
within the academy by by acting together
by thinking through these with a sense
of urgency by trying to reform
institutions in ways that preserve
academic freedom that enhance
knowledge production and things like
that but if if these problems continue
to be ignored
by us they're not being ignored you know
outside and eventually
probably sooner rather than later these
outside actors are going to be able
and actually already are but will
probably be increasingly able
to threaten academic freedom threaten
autonomy of
of professors and institutions of higher
learning very hard
hard-fought economy um that
organizations like the aaa
up and the aac and you have been
fighting to preserve since 1910
already tenure is being eroded radically
i mean
like something like 70 of of
new academic appointments today or
non-tenure track and even for people who
are on the tenure track
you know are sometimes being fired for
um for uh
you know political reasons um and so
so these are these are problems it's
still within our capacity to to
help sort of resolve some of these
problems ourselves but it won't be that
way forever
so that's that's kind of the urgency
that we have for for trying to sort of
resolve
um some of these issues let me let me uh
even take the
lens back a little bit more to a wider
perspective here because
these issues of why it's good
in the academy you forget about politics
and forget i i like
the points you just made don't get me
wrong but uh if i'm
just worried about being the best
intellectual i can be
being the best uh thinker about thing um
you've written interesting essays on the
role of critique
and and how it's so important
to have this attitude i guess
towards ideas that we should be
suspicious of them in in some sense and
i
somehow if we put aside you know modern
politics and contemporary worries
there is this fundamental value or
orientation difference in my mind that
that maybe maps onto some of these
questions between people who say look
um most changes that we could make to
the present system
would be bad you know we've been we
spent a lot of time coming up with the
present system and so like
don't ruin it uh just for the sake of
change and those people will be labeled
conservatives and other people will say
well it's clear the present system can't
be the best system we have you know
there's all sorts of
uh influences on it that are not
oriented towards making things they can
so our job is to undermine
the present system and you know how do
we balance in a very broad sense the
project of being the best intellectual
we can given these you know competing
fairly reasonable sounding claim yeah
and um
and actually i think you put your your
thumb pretty
firmly on the issue of of for instance
why conservative perspectives would be
more valuable um in the academy than a
lot of people understand
uh and it's this it's precisely this
orientation towards
tradition and um concern about things
like
um you know harm caused by naive
interventionism
um the fact that the things that persist
uh sometimes persist for a reason
uh and that if we don't understand sort
of how they came about
and why they persist then when we change
things we can often make things worse
and you know history is replete with
examples of
of people trying to make radical changes
to society
and at not one not working out how they
anticipated but two
you know not just them failing to
achieve their
planned objectives but making things far
far far
worse i mean sometimes sliding into just
outright totalitarianism and famine and
things like that
um so so there is i mean and so you
really need these two
these two but at the same time you know
absent the sort of progressive impulse
to of critique and um of critiquing the
prevailing order
and looking for improvement right then
you you get stagnation and
uh and um and similarly it's those those
are social orders that also tend not to
be per
to persist because they aren't
responsive to contemporary needs with
contemporary concerns priorities so you
really need these
orientations to be in dialogue with one
another
you did half of uh of answering the
question i mean you gave a good
uh pep talk for uh taking on board
the more conservative notion of let's be
suspicious of proposed changes right but
there is the you know the leftist
progressive liberal point of view of
let's be suspicious of the present
system as well which which also
serves a purpose and you know i know
that you value that purpose as well so
maybe i'll give you a chance to say
something about that
oh yeah absolutely um well okay so uh
yeah so i mean one one one fact of the
matter is
that um part of the reason that social
orders exist
is usually because they solve sort of
specific problems and
that gave rise to that caused the the
collapse of the previous order and that
led to the emergence of the new one and
part of the reason why it's stable is
because it actually is working pretty
well for a lot of people but
it's often the case that there are a
number of people for whom the prevailing
order does not work and has never worked
and there are people
people who are excluded and marginalized
at this advantage
um and um and they matter too
right uh so and
and so this is one of one of the sources
of
critique of the prevailing social order
often comes from these people
for whom the social order isn't working
well for people who are marginalized
and disenfranchised additionally you
know um
social orders come into being usually uh
in a particular context a particular
historical context face
you know in response to particular
challenges from particular actors but
you know the world evolves
situations evolve um the the challenges
change
and to the extent that society can't
change
with them then it tends again then that
social order tends not to survive so
for both of those reasons one to help um
to help uh elevate and um ensure the
dignity of
people for whom this cultural order
previously
has not that social order has not been
serving well and then two to make sure
that social order sort of um is
responsive to contemporary needs and
correcting circumstances right
um this is why that impulse towards
critique and that impulse towards
uh change matters and is important and
is like
absolutely essential i mean literally
against social orders tended
to collapse or die without that impulse
as well um
and so these are perspectives that that
that need to be put in
into contact with one another one ironic
thing though i'll say and actually this
is the
this is why they need to be put in
dialogue with each other is that the
the sort of the impulse to critique is
usually other oriented
yes right um or you usually are
critiquing again things you disagree
with
uh things that that aren't working well
for you you're critiquing people who are
your
perceived to be your ideological
adversaries or whatever
and and again that a lack of reflexivity
of turning the critical lens towards
oneself towards the actors that one
agrees with towards the causes that one
agrees with or sympathizes with
is often the reason why these sort of
well-intentioned
things go awry it's because you know
with the critique-oriented people the
change-oriented people are focused on
changing
and critiquing everyone else um
and uh and so they're the ones who are
wrong diversity is important
um this is why it can't just be all of
the
if you have the critique centered people
that somehow
you know um that that it'll be
self-correcting with just those people
as because you need um you need the lens
to be turned
uh turned against the people who are who
are making that
those critiques well it's it's uh i
agree
you i you know but it i worry
that it gets a bit utopian i mean i i
worry that in a world where there are
plenty of people
who are willing to critique me uh and
you're asking me to now
join them in critiquing me this couldn't
i
you know better spend my time critiquing
the wrong people rather than myself
but i think but i think you know i say
that jokingly because it is important
because
you know on the one hand we should have
some convictions and move forward on the
basis of them and at the same time we
should be always
questioning that we haven't gotten
things right it's just so difficult to
pull off in practice
well and one reason why it's important
um a flag
is that uh is actually this is super
important for trying to help people
from historically marginalized and
disadvantaged groups so one irony
um for instance is that so for instance
look at african americans or hispanic
um or or lower socioeconomic status
people
the people who are not well served by
the basically they tend to
they they often skew more socially
conservative so like blacks and
hispanics are most socially conservative
on average than whites um so are
many immigrant communities um they're
also more religious
on average than whites and uh low
socioeconomic
status people the same way compared to
upper pseudoeconomic status people
and so if you create an environment
that's hostile
towards for instance socially
conservative or religious views
that will disproportionately affect
people of color
it will disproportionately affect
immigrants it will disproportionately
affect you know first generation
students lower socioeconomic students so
often so sometimes what happens is in
the very name of
championing people from disadvantaged
groups we alienate and ignore some of
those very people
and it's important if you want to help
promote the interests of say
african americans to listen to what
african-americans actually want
so for instance with respect to police
reform there's a movement to defund the
police but if you ask
black people do you want to defund the
police um
they overwhelmingly say no they want
substantive police reform
they want to end discrimination but they
want police in their communities like
communities dealing with crime
with violent crime you know want police
and and
you know a lot of times i i've written
extensively about police reform
and this is always a check on me as well
that i try to
to check myself when i get a little too
uh amped up about the problems with law
enforcement
and it's trying to keep in mind the fact
that
you know i come from a very particular
position um
i'm i'm at an ivy league school you know
i'm i'm not from a wealthy background
i started at community college and
whatever but like the milieu in which
i'm currently
in mesh and the environment in wuchang
is very different
from from that of of most
african-americans um
similarly you you know and so for
substantial things like that and then
even for more
where where oftentimes the the desires
and
opinions of the very people you're
supposedly championing
are being ignored and that that happens
in substantial issues that also happens
in trivial issues like for instance
the term latinx is often championed as
a as the proper way of referring to
people of um hispanic or latino origin
but if you ask people of hispanic or
latino origin
do you like the term latinx do you
consider yourself
this like overwhelmingly like you know
80
20 they say no we don't like this term
this doesn't
even even when you ask people of uh
there's a great
uh essay report that just came out in
the new york times where
for instance um a lot of speech coded as
racist dog whistles so usually they
would take
say some rhetoric from trump and they
would say this is a dog whistle
that appeals to sort of white supremacy
white supremacist leanings or whatever
and so because they come with this
analytical frame it never occurs to a
lot of it didn't occur to a lot of
researchers to like
ask people of color how they understood
these comments because the researchers
said
that's racist right they didn't ask do
you find this racist
um but when they did that uh it turned
out
that a lot of um that black people
were no less likely than white people
that the the messages resonated just as
strongly with blacks as with whites and
resonated even more strongly with
hispanics than african americans or
whites so these frog whistles
resonated more strongly with minorities
than with white people
and people across the board wouldn't
find them uh
racist similarly with microaggressions
you can when you present
um black and hispanic uh people with
canonical micro
microaggressions and ask them do you
find this defensive
overwhelmingly they do not find them
offensive let alone harmful
and the reason that this matters that
this microaggressions
fact matters is because we do know from
research however that
when people perceive themselves to have
been the target of racism or
discrimination
that that corresponds to a number of
negative emotional
effects mental health effects even just
physical health effects so
sensitizing people more to these things
that they don't currently find offensive
so taking people of color and teaching
them that they should be offended by
these things that they're not currently
offended by
would probably correlate with worse
mental health outcomes
worth physical outcomes worse you know
interpersonal outcomes for minorities
by trying to sensitize them to these
slights that they don't find offensive
right now
ostensibly in the name of promoting
their own interests right
um so it's important so i guess the
shorthand is oftentimes
disturbingly this impulse to champion
people from historically marginalized
and underrepresented group oftentimes
scholars ignore those very people whose
interests are championing
and well and i'll say they don't
necessarily ignore them entirely what
they
what happens is you'll have elites who
represent those groups
basically who are whose views are not
representative
whose views are more in line with other
white elites than with
the typical black or hispanic person
will be serving as the
as the sort of lead on the the reference
point
for other academics about what is in
black hispanic people's interests so for
instance people
are going to consult tanishi coats about
well what do black people want what's
good for black people
let's see what codes has to say right
rather than like let's poll
african-americans right
um and uh and that and that's a problem
right because coates is a
um again he's great uh you know but he's
his views on the world are demonstrably
out of touch his
his socioeconomic position is
demonstrably out of step
etc with the typical black or hispanic
person so if you're looking at coats to
understand what's best for the typical
black or hispanic person
you're probably going to be led astray
um and this is the trap that we fall
into let me uh i think we're closing up
here so
let me just sort of give you an open
question that you can uh
answer as you choose um i mean a lot of
these
individual specific issues we've been
talking about play into the
question of the role of the intellectual
in
modern society and i think the word
intellectual has even become
uh hard to take seriously in some sense
like if you call yourself intellectual
you're pretentious
and it's used you know in a sort of
denigrating sense in some way
uh there's a feeling that we live in a
world where the discourse
is not really uh fundamentally
intellectually oriented
uh what do you think about that
situation we're in and does it turn into
any specific advice you could give
on would-be or current intellectuals out
there yeah i mean it
uh it's it's i definitely um
hear that i mean i've i've had to
struggle a lot myself even
i mean again i don't come from a
background where
where the word intellectual would be
understood as the positive thing it
would be a
derisive thing you said about someone um
so it's been a journey myself to
understand
myself as an intellectual in a non um
i guess you know anyway uh so i i mean i
guess my advice to people
one one bit of advice for people is that
i think academics have been kind of
bad at explaining things like you know
why our work wire work matters
connecting the the work we do to the
needs and priorities
of ordinary people and this matters
especially
i think for scholars at institutions
that are paid for largely
through taxpayer fund um you know i feel
like
a lot of taxpayers and politicians who
represent them
feel like and not unreasonably that if
they're making these large investments
in these institutions of higher learning
that there should be some kind of
benefit to them or society or whatever
you know that
emerges out of this investment that the
public is making in these institutions
and i don't know
that intellectuals have been have done
an excellent job
of explaining what that benefit is and
this
and so i guess one one plank is that i
think intellectuals
need to do better at engaging with the
public
um you know uh talking about their
research in more accessible and
compelling ways
ordinary people um engaging in more
events
outside of the academy to engage with
you know just people
in their communities um and and their
needs and priorities and concerns
connecting their scholarship to sort of
practical matters that people care about
that's one plan oh but but i will say
there are there are actually some great
organizations out there
that who that whose purpose is to help
connect academics to the public such as
scholar strategy network
or the frameworks institute has good
work about um how to talk about matters
in a compelling way
uh to the public um and and i think i
think that that would
uh i think that that would help um yeah
well i think it's some good advice it's
uh i think you've given us a lot to
think about musa algarvi thanks so much
for being on the mindscape podcast
thank you for having
[Music]
you